en el día de ayer se registraba el
incendio por ejemplo de un templo
evangélico y otro templo católico en la
zona sur del país en la región donde hay
una población mayoritaria mapuche son
los reiterados hechos de violencia que
han ocurrido en las últimas semanas y
que llevan ocurriendo durante décadas
los que llevó al presidente sebastián
piñera a declarar ayer el estado de
excepción y emergencia en esta zona que
tendrá una duración de 15 días
renovables otros 15 días más esto
después de que la contraloría rechazara
una medida para que las fuerzas armadas
realizarán patrullajes en la zona lo que
significa este estado de excepción es
que controla sobre todo la locomoción y
la reunión hace controles en las
entradas y las salidas y también permite
que quede al cargo de la zona un
almirante y un general en la región del
bío bío y la región de la araucanía a
más de 700 kilómetros al sur de santiago
también que las fuerzas armadas puedan
colaborar con la policía pero no
sustituir a la policía en las tareas de
orden público esto debido a que
a los hechos de narcotráfico terrorismo
y crimen organizado según señaló el
presidente sebastián piñera patricia le
pregunto entonces el reclamo de los
indígenas mapuches
como bien decía el domingo se registraba
una manifestación la manifestación de
resistencia indígena la que es
tradicional en estas fechas en las que
cientos de personas la mayoría de ellos
de pueblos originarios pero también otro
tipo de otro tipo de chilenos se unen
para pedir la restitución de las tierras
ancestrales para la población indígena y
también la liberación de lo que los
presos políticos de las personas que
están detenidas en esa zona por vivir
diversos hechos son normalmente
manifestaciones que se realizan también
contra empresas forestales que tienen
ocupadas muchas partes de los
territorios que se consideran
ancestrales y que tienen que ser
restituidos los pueblos originarios sus
pueblos mapuche están en la calle y
llevan una lucha de más de 500 años para
conseguir la restitución de estos
territorios y también para permitir que
las para permitir la defensa de los
entornos medioambientales en contra de
las empresas forestales multinacionales
que son que tienen una gran mayoría de
terreno en esa zona del país